across the kitchen floor, saying,
"I think you people might need food in there."
(Laughter)
Week three, celebrities — Entertainment Tonight,
Access Hollywood.
Week four, global — BBC, Irish Radio.
Did anyone see "Lost In Translation"?
My husband did Japanese television.
It was interesting.
(Laughter)
And those videos, the popular ones.
Paul Bissonnette's glacier video, incredible.
How about the redemption nuns of Dublin?
Who's seen that one?
It's absolutely fantastic.
J.T., Justin Timberlake.
That's when we knew, that was a real A-list celebrity.
I go back on my texts, and I can see
"JT! JT!" My sister texting me.
Angela Merkel, the chancellor of Germany.
Incredible.
And the ALS patients,
you know what their favorite ones are, and their families'?
All of them.
Because this misunderstood and underfunded "rare" disease,
they just sat and watched people saying it over and over: "ALS, ALS."
It was unbelievable.
And those naysayers,
let's just talk a couple of stats, shall we?
Okay, so the ALS Association,
they think by year end, it'll be 160 million dollars.
ALS TDI in Cambridge,
they raised three million dollars.
Well, guess what?
They had a clinical trial for a drug that they've been developing.
It was on a three-year track for funding.
Two months.
It's coming out starting in two months.
(Applause)
And YouTube has reported
that over 150 countries have posted Ice Bucket Challenges for ALS.
And Facebook, 2.5 million videos,
and I had the awesome adventure
visiting the Facebook campus last week,
and I said to them, "I know what it was like in my house.
I can't imagine what it was like around here."
All she said was, "Jaw-dropping."
And my family's favorite video?
Bill Gates.
Because the night Pete was diagnosed,
he told us that he was going to get ALS in front of philanthropists like Bill Gates,
and he did it.
Goal number one, check.
Now on to the treatment and cure.
(Applause)
So okay, after all of this ice,
we know that it was much more
than just pouring buckets of ice water over your head,
and I really would like to leave you
with a couple of things that I'd like you to remember.
The first thing is,
every morning when you wake up,
you can choose to live your day in positivity.
Would any of you blame me
if I just was in the fetal position
and pulled the covers over my head every day?
No, I don't think anybody would blame me,
but Pete has inspired us to wake up
every morning and be positive and proactive.
I actually had to ditch support groups
because everybody was in there saying that
spraying their lawns with chemicals,
that's why they got ALS,
and I was like, "I don't think so,"
but I had to get away from the negativity.
The second thing I want to leave you with
is the person at the middle of the challenge
has to be willing to have the mental toughness
to put themselves out there.
Pete still goes to baseball games
and he still sits with his teammates in the dugout,
and he hangs his gravity feed bag
right on the cages.
You'll see the kids, they're up there hanging it up.
"Pete, is that okay?" "Yup."
And then they put it right into his stomach.
Because he wants them to see what the reality of this is,
and how he's never, ever going to give up.
And the third thing I want to leave you with:
If you ever come across a situation
that you see as so unacceptable,
I want you to dig down as deep as you can
and find your best mother bear
and go after it.
(Applause)
Thank you.
I know that I'm running over,
but I've got to leave you with this:
the gifts that my son has given me.
I have had 29 years
of having the honor of being the mother
of Pete Frates.
Pete Frates has been inspiring and leading his whole life.
He's thrown out kindness,
and all that kindness has come back to him.
He walks the face of the Earth right now and knows why he's here.
What a gift.
The second thing that my son has given me
is he's given me my mission in life.
Now I know why I'm here.
I'm going to save my son,
and if it doesn't happen in time for him,
I'm going to work so that no other mother
has to go through what I'm going through.
And the third thing, and last but not least
gift that my son has given me,
as an exclamation point
to the miraculous month
of August 2014:
That girlfriend that he went to get on the night of diagnosis is now his wife,
and Pete and Julie have given me my granddaughter, Lucy Fitzgerald Frates.
Lucy Fitzgerald Frates came two weeks early
as the exclamation point
on August 31st, 2014.
And so —
(Applause) —
And so let me leave you with Pete's words of inspiration
that he would use to classmates, coworkers and teammates.
Be passionate.
Be genuine.
Be hardworking.
And don't forget to be great.
Thank you. (Applause)